as an artist coming from a conflict zone
created by male dominant behavior I was
forced to seek freedom from the
political physical and psychological
constraint that defined my environment
in order to do this I began to make work
that was inspired by an artistic
movement born of creativity range and
the individualism of the aims as an
artist I searched for extreme situation
and people that have body possibilities
of freedom and I'm fascinated by the gap
between what we are and what we want to
be
I explore identity through photographing
videotaping collecting texts and
collaborating with individual that
informed no radical persona my
relationship with each person shifts
according to the specific historical
context political conflict and cultural
issues that I address through the
exposition of the personal by
establishing close relationship with my
subject we begin to search together for
different ways to awaken the body and to
elicit the self through the construction
of different characters since childhood
I have envisioned the classic children
hero Pippi Longstocking is my alter ego
because she's a rebellious character the
socially subversive ideas
you